So Fox news has been a topic of discussion
lately.
Are they with Trump fully or are they with
Trump partially or might they abandon Trump
in the 2020 election during yesterday's impeachment
inquiry hearings, Fox news was fully, fully,
fully, fully with Donald Trump, including
not only their coverage after the fact defending
Donald Trump, but I want to look at some of
the onscreen graphics that they aired during
the hearings.
So you might remember that, uh, over the last
couple of years there have been networks who
have chosen to do something that I think is
really important when Donald Trump is giving
a speech and telling lie after lie after lie.
They try to FactCheck Trump in real time.
So Trump is speaking and there will be graphics
on screen that present facts about the things
Donald Trump is lying about it.
They don't do it all the time, but it's been
tested by some networks.
When Donald Trump is speaking, Trump tells
a lie and the truth shows up on the screen
and it's a pretty useful thing.
Fox did a version of this but it's Fox.
So they actually did the opposite during yesterday's
hearings.
They put up lies and unsubstantiated allegations
about the witnesses on screen or the people
asking questions on screen as if they were
fact.
They took, uh, attacks from Donald Trump on
the witnesses and on the members of Congress
asking questions and put them on screen as
if they were facts that you should be aware
of in order to understand what was happening
during the hearings.
So let's look at some examples.
This first one is when Adam Schiff was speaking,
and it's really important to do this so that
you understand the way the propaganda cycle
works.
And it's also really important because one
of the main criticisms from Republicans of
the witnesses was they are presenting hearsay
and they are just saying what they heard from
someone else.
What Fox news was putting up on screen were
unproven allegations and claims, which during
the hearings Republicans said we shouldn't
actually be doing, we shouldn't be basing
our opinion on things that are unproven claims.
And then Fox puts up unproven claims and assertions.
So first of all, Fox news puts up as a fact
that quote Adam Schiff publicly exaggerated
the substance of the Trump's Olenski phone
call on nine 26 September 26th shifts said
that the transcript of the Trump phone call
reads like a classic organized crime shakedown.
Now this was shifts interpretation.
It was made sort of satirically.
I mean, you know, it's hyperbolic language.
It's like an organized crime shape.
Shakedown shift said he's not literally saying
that.
He said, you know, in some and character,
this was what the president was trying to
communicate.
And of course it was that phone call was part
of a bigger picture.
Attempted shakedown of president Zelenskyi
of Ukraine.
And in reality shifts summary, even partially
satirical, using hyperbolic language was far
more accurate than the way Donald Trump and
his defenders have summarized that phone call.
Fox news, putting that onscreen as it's a
fat as if it's the fact.
Also on screen at the time, Fox puts on screen
that quote, Schiff admitted to not being clear
about contact with the whistle blower.
We still have no evidence that Adam Schiff
was in contact with a whistle blower.
There is no evidence that shift helped a shift,
helped write the whistleblower complaint as
has been alleged.
The white, uh, the whistleblower did go to
a house intelligence committee aid who said,
listen, you need to get a lawyer and you need
to file a formal complaint.
And that aid told Adam Schiff about that.
Again, a totally distorted claim on screen.
Let's go to the next one.
This next one gets absolutely ridiculous and
understand that for the Fox news audience,
this becomes gospel.
This becomes the truth about the impeachment
hearings.
Fox put up a graphic that says Trump has repeatedly
implied that shift committed treason.
Now, that is absolutely true in the sense
that Trump has implied that, but why is that?
On the screen?
You could put actual facts about the circumstances
on the screen, but instead they put up an
unfounded ad hominem attack from the president
on a member of Congress.
Treason is defined very clearly in the constitution.
Schiff clearly did not do anything treasonous.
Why would you put that on the screen?
Well, to poison the well, of course.
Then we get to the graphics for former Ukraine
ambassador William Taylor, which there may
be even worse.
Fox puts on screen next to Taylor's face that
quote, president Trump dismissed Taylor as
a never Trumper.
Now, once again, it is true that Trump said
that, but that's not something any serious
news outlet puts on screen during a hearing.
If the goal is to better the understanding
of the audience about the substance of what's
being alleged, especially when there is no
evidence that Taylor is a so-called never
Trump or period.
There's really nothing else to debunk.
Other than that, I mean there's no evidence.
It's not relevant to the hearings.
Fox news decided that the most important things
to tell their audience about shifts and Taylor
are unsubstantiated attacks made by president
Trump.
They're doing Trump's dirty work.
That's ultimately what this comes down to.
So when you watch the hearings, you might
might've been annoyed as I sort of was that
so much time was spent by Democrats clarifying
the reputations and the credentials of the
witnesses and the witnesses talking about,
you know, George kept talking about he's,
I think he said the fourth George Kent, uh,
or Kent from his family to be serving the
government or whatever.
Many of us deemed it unnecessary.
We wanted to get to the substance, but this
is part of why it had to be done because in
real time, Republicans bolstered with the
support of right wing media and Republicans,
uh, uh, Republicans and right wing media together
were attempting to smear Adam Schiff.
They were attempting to Smeal smear William
Taylor.
They were attempting to smear George Kent
and it was happening on screen in real time
on Fox news.
So listen, we don't know ultimately what role
Fox news will choose to play in Donald Trump's
reelection campaign for 2020, as we said,
very different circumstances than under George
W. Bush in 2004.
We don't know if there'll be fully, partially
or not at all with Trump for his reelection,
but at least as far as the impeachment inquiry
hearings go, they have been Trump's dirty
work henchmen, the equivalent of whoever went
up to stormy Daniels in that garage and implicitly
threatened Stormy's daughter, I believe it
was.
They were doing that work.
Fox news was during the hearings.
We will have more examples of this on our
Instagram page.
Follow us there at David Pakman show
and while you're there, give me a follow on
Instagram at David dot Pacman.
I posted a funny behind the scenes picture
from the studio earlier today, but I think
you would enjoy, uh, in a very serious matter